well, these multi-talented geniuses have so
much potential that I
would actually find it a shame if they only
made one company what they
have to manage is that the team
behind them also carries out the execution accordingly
there is this one Frenchman who, for
example, is de facto the  CEO of Tesla the
whole time was my servant Kinzig
had brought a great decision and
you always have teams who
supported the founders of google and
visionaries or on Facebook at the time at
beiserkerberg or Erik Schmidt the
corresponding is
that's the
decisive mixture that you have
the Schumpeter and entrepreneur but at the
same time you also have the
best teams that then implement things